[Música]
bienvenidos a medio ambiente desde casa
en france24 este programa lo dedicamos a
las semanas regionales del clima que
comienzan oficialmente esta primera
semana de marzo durante la que se
establecen las prioridades climáticas de
cada región sus desafíos y también qué
oportunidades existen en ellas para la
acción estos encuentros en los que se
unen gobiernos sector privado ongs y el
mundo académico forman parte de la
preparación previa a la cumbre sobre el
cambio climático de la onu que se
celebra en glasgow escocia pero de aquí
a que los países del mundo se reúnan en
noviembre en la cob 26 hay mucho trabajo
por hacer un trabajo que he hecho de
manera regional puede resultar en
acciones climáticas más amplias y con un
mayor impacto para conocer más acerca de
la semana del clima regional de américa
latina y el caribe entrevistamos a mcs
week vicepresidente ejecutivo del
consejo nacional para el cambio
climático y mecanismo de desarrollo
limpio de república dominicana que este
año es el país anfitrión nos habló de la
importancia de la unión regional para
conseguir los resultados deseados y
también para poder exigir a los países
emisores mayores compromisos
cierto hay una responsabilidad universal
en cuanto a la generación de gases de
efecto invernadero
pero
no todos los países son los somos
igualmente responsables de su generación
y sin embargo en cuanto a los efectos
los países de la región era muy
particular en los países de los países
insulares pues también bien recibidos
estos reciben los signos mismos aspectos
de manera mucho más mucho más severa
la cuestión es cómo establecemos puntos
de vista en común para él
participar en la mediación para también
exigir a los países tienen mayor
responsabilidad en la generación de
cumplan con sus compromisos
incluso ha subido respecto a la
mitigación del cambio climático pero
también quiere establecer medidas que
contribuyan a la adaptación de los
países de la región
según we que es una carrera contrarreloj
y la semana de américa latina y el
caribe al ser la región que menos
emisiones produce a nivel global pero
una de las más afectadas por los
impactos del cambio climático se
centrará en cómo hacer que la balanza se
equilibre es decir en que haya justicia
ambiental
hay una vibración
una muy muy extendida en el mundo y es
realmente poder desarrollar conceptos de
la justicia climática de excelente
medida los países
están recibiendo estamos recibiendo la
mayor parte de los efectos adversos o
negativos del cambio climático es decir
podemos ser atendidos incluso como puede
no ser recompensadas la idea de nosotros
es trabajar el tema de daños y
perjuicios de modo que las medidas de
adaptación que se se tomen fueron
realmente es de alguna manera de
resarcir ante todo se bajó de lugar a
plenitud pero que en nuestros países de
américa latina y el caribe podamos
enfrentar en mejores condiciones
el fenómeno esto claro está a parte del
compromiso general de contribuir a un
compromiso de una salud es contribuir a
la mitigación del fenómeno y lograr el
objetivo no solamente de gente
gastélum y de las temperaturas dentro
grados y luego incluso logran alcanzar
el objetivo de g
en relación a tura no sobrepase el 1 el
1 y medio
literal los principales retos
ambientales de república dominicana que
aumentó su compromiso de reducción de
emisiones y aspirar a ser carbono
neutral antes de 2050 son compartidos
por muchos otros países de la zona y al
final se convierten en problemas
económicos que amenazan la subsistencia
de la población
nacional
y su poema más emblemático se llama hay
un país en el mundo que comienza
diciendo que hay un país en el mundo
colocado en el mismo proyecto del sol
es cierto muy bello pero además estar
colocado en el mismo trayecto son
nuestro país está colocado en las rutas
los huracanes hospitales en todos los
estados insulares del caribe y no
solamente los estados insulares sino los
países de la región mesoamericana
estamos justamente afectados por estos
fenómenos de los extremos cada vez más
frecuentes
no solamente los fenómenos el régimen de
lluvias las sequías las inundaciones
en fin
esto es la elevación la elevación del
nivel del nivel del mar que también está
afectando lo que es la columna vertebral
de nuestra economía la economía
dominicana se suscita hoy totalmente en
el turismo y frente a la erosión de las
playas pues lo que es realmente un
problema realmente muy muy viciado
estos eventos como dijimos se dividen
por región y coinciden con las zonas de
países en desarrollo
américa latina y el caribe áfrica y
asia-pacífico cada una con sus fechas
específicas para estas semanas
regionales del clima el año que viene se
unirá la región de medio oriente y el
norte de áfrica max puig que espera que
haya una participación plena y
productiva en la semana del clima para
que en agosto se hayan logrado unas
posiciones comunes de la región que
permitan hacer aportes significativos
durante la cop 26 en noviembre es todo
por esta semana sigan con más en france
24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]